so hot the hem Sasha doubts the very
first wheel crafted by mankind looked
like this one we don't know today who
that inventor was but we do know that
Karl Benz revolutionized the world with
his version of the motorized passenger
car in 1886 back in 1914 years after
Karl Benzes patent global car sales
totaled 9500 for the stats for 2013
aren't out yet but the figure for last
year is expected to be around 87 million
preferences for class of car and brand
vary from country to country but what
about the actual process of buying a new
car
I'm del vaga not for our first example
sasha is outside cologne to talk to
Martin servidio he's interested in the
particular car buying a new car can be a
very emotional affair in Germany at
least customers here love perusing the
infinite array of special offers to put
together their dream abeel eighty or
ninety percent of customers who come to
the dealership are very well prepared
they've studied online and know what
they want internet so inform you of them
listen to lhasa balan as but Martin
looks out for is the right balance of
performance and safety it is important
when you have children once that's four
million photos ultimate often dinkus
what are the priorities for people from
other parts of the world the price
economics efficiency for me it has to be
the price and how much it will cause you
to maintain the car afterwards price
price brand and dependability Oh for me
importance that not brand by the very
strong car port avio economical not much
variation on that front end but there is
a big difference as regards another
factor I'd have to wait 16 weeks for a
pre-configured new car yes I waited over
six months the first time around three
months though it's all human car buyers
are prepared to wait if I get their car
exactly as desired the same is not true
worldwide however as sasha is going to
show us both wagon sold more cars in
America than any other german producer
last year sasha is outside the biggest
VW dealership in New York to get
exclusive insights into the buying
habits of stateside customers all night
endemic on again Americans bought an
estimated 11.2 million cars in 2013 with
a population of 317 million that
translates into a new car for one and 28
people
hello welcome to Volkswagen of Manhattan
sasha is wondering where all the cars
are hunters well we have 150 cars and
stop on the roof about to see a roof
covered in cars not something you see
every day sasha wants to know what the
procedure is when a customer comes in
here what's special here in Manhattan is
that the customer comes in to the
showroom and they test drive the car
today they also take a look at the car
inside and out and in most cases they
take the car home the same day or if not
today within one business day dealers
have to stock more vehicles on site than
in say Germany and as buying such a
quantity would be beyond the financial
means of most dealerships they don't
actually buy vehicles from the
manufacturer until they found a buyer
unlike in Germany where customers can
configure the car themselves buyers in
the u.s. of only a handful of variations
to choose from but dealers can swap cars
with a partner business if say the
desired body color is not in stock Jack
Viren is buying a new car would he wait
six months
so it would be difficult it would have
to be something real special
now be very high can't imagine what that
per year the view of most of his fellow
Americans oh it was there so I took it
immediately Matt got my car the same day
I usually just buy it the day of your in
dealership if you have the money or the
financing option you just walk out the
day of if you if you have it for three
years fun Angie it's the way we do
things in America it's always simpler
and things seemed to be getting simpler
for customers in Germany to now why not
follow our German dealer guesses that
eighty to eighty-five percent of
purchases he's processed in the last
couple years are on credit those who pay
it all in cash like in the 1960s and 70s
are a dying breed dr. pols car sales in
the US are also heavily influenced by
fluctuations in fuel prices weekends
when gasoline is cheap see more people
buying cars as the price of the pump
goes up sales decline the business of
car buying is in many ways an impulsive
issue in America
you